so let me on that topic could be
interesting as a little side
tour what are your thoughts in this year
about gpt3
and these language models and these
transformers is there something
interesting
to you as an ai researcher or is there
something interesting to you
as an autonomous vehicle developer nah i
think uh
i think it's overhyped i mean it's not
like it's cool it's cool for what it is
but no
we're not just gonna be able to scale up
to gpg 12 and get general purpose
intelligence
like your loss function is literally
just
you know you know cross-entropy loss on
the character right like that's not the
loss function of general intelligence
is that obvious to you yes can you
imagine that
like to play devil's advocate on
yourself is it possible
that you can the gpt-12 will achieve
general intelligence
with something as dumb as this kind of
loss function
i guess it depends what you mean by
general intelligence
so there's another problem with the gpts
and that's that they don't have
a uh they don't have long-term memory
right right so like just
gpt 12 a scaled up version of gpt two or
three
i find it hard to believe
well you can scale it in it's yeah so
it's a hardcore hard-coded length but
you can
make it wider and wider and wider yeah
you're gonna get you're gonna get cool
things from those systems
but i i don't think you're ever gonna
get something that can like
you know build me a rocket ship what
about soft driving
so you know you can use transformer with
video for example
you think is there something in there no
because
we use we as a group we use a group we
could change that group out to a
transformer
um i think driving is much more
markovian than language
so markov you mean like the memory which
which aspect of
uh i mean that like most of the
information
in the state at t minus one is also in
the in is in state
right and it kind of like drops off
nicely like this where sometime with
language you have to refer back to the
third
paragraph on the second page i feel like
there's not
many like like you can say like speed
limit signs but there's really not many
things in autonomous driving that look
like that
but if you look at uh to play devil's
advocate
is uh the risk estimation thing that
you've talked about is kind of
interesting
is uh it feels like there might be some
longer term
uh aggregation of context necessary to
be able to figure out like
the context yeah i'm not even sure i'm
i'm believing my my own devil we have a
nice we have a nice like vision model
which outputs like a
a one or two four-dimensional perception
space um
can i try transformers on it sure i
probably will
at some point we'll try transformers and
then we'll just see do they do better
sure
i'm well it might not be a game changer
no well i'm not like like
might transformers work better than
grooves for autonomous driving sure
might we switch sure is this some
radical change no
okay we use a slightly different you
know we switch from rnn's to grooves
like
okay maybe it's greased to transformers
but no it's not
you